[Music]
i basically live life like this
i know i mean nothing in the universe
and i wake up every day trying to be the
most important human on earth
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
awesome well thanks for being here um
yeah you're right i feel like all of our
interactions together have been either
we've been being interviewed i don't
know if you remember but our first
interview together was at the
is that good morning america and i i
i remember being like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna
have to like go
i have to go toe-to-toe with this guy he
talks a lot
and i was like and he but it was awesome
what you had to say but i was like
[ __ ] start interrupting him because he's
going to take the show
and that's my first you know and then i
love him
he was great i remember she was great
because yeah we
you're like oh we have to talk and i
felt like an intense pressure
because he was like on a roll saying all
this smart [ __ ] and i was like [ __ ]
i gotta start saying smart stuff i gotta
interrupt him and
so that was but you know what's funny i
remember you know it's one of those
things you remember what you feel but
not every detail of the words
i the reason i said we should get
together is i'm in those settings a lot
yeah uh you're right i feel good about
my craft if i'm talking about what i
know
it's gonna roll it's gonna be sharp
strong historically true
and very current and oftentimes
that takes up too much oxygen and i
remember
and and when i saw it i remember just
feeling vividly i'm like oh wait a
minute
be thoughtful here because she's got
juice too
and i'm never thinking that actually
yeah i remember vividly
because i really liked what you were
saying too it was very strong
which is you know i'm a tough filter i
really don't think most people are
not only great first of all you actually
executed which always wins me over
right it wasn't like you were a
professor i love professors but
you had already actually executed the
first thing you said i don't remember at
all but i remember how i felt was strong
and i remember that very vividly
actually
huh yeah well those are those were the
early days when
you and i first became buddies and it
felt yeah i mean it was it was good it
was good for me you know because i felt
really challenged and i felt like i have
to like raise the bar on myself
you know which is so much of like i feel
like what you're about
and every time you know even like i have
a 14 and 16 year old son and they listen
to you
a lot you know and it's it's just it's
really awesome
what you've done and i mean i feel like
if i catch i'm scrolling instagram and i
catch one of your things like i always
stop and listen
so it's an honor to have you on the show
and big honor
yeah i mean even for me too just to add
my two cents to that i've been listening
to you uh i don't feels like forever i
guess maybe eight years or so
i remember you in my years at the ymca
and that would have been like
eight or ten years ago or something um
and uh
even i was as i was thinking about
jumping into this call thinking about
what i what
do i really appreciate about you and
it's
there's the expertise there's the
freshness fresh voice and all that
but really what you've what you've done
is take a stand
to speak i think both liberating and
convicting truth to an upcoming
generation that most people gave up on
it's so easy to give up on like the
millennial generation but really you've
spoken right to them saying hey
the entitlement's going to kill you and
the the short term
the short term aim is going to kill you
be patient
care about people more respect yourself
enough to be honest with your parents
go take a stand i mean all the themes of
which you know are really you and how
you've lived
have really made such a difference so
thank you for that i mean your
commitment
it's been really rare uh in in the
content world
it you're thank you i don't you know i'm
not even gonna i want to get into the
interview like i really am living it i
you know you two will know this and
everybody listening knows this
there is nobody on earth that you
remotely know more than yourself
you're not even close right close not
your mother
your your lover your best friend your
your sister your brother
you the death is enormous it's actually
enormous you know
everything about yourself you might want
to be delusional and trick yourself
but you know you know yeah yeah and
and there's a lot you don't know even
with the people you're closest to that's
just
actually the way it is yep i know
exactly what i'm up to
yep right like i know i am
desperate for the scratching
of the curiosity of how much positive
impact can i have
well but what's so fascinating and what
i i watch you and i'm always like you
know i
when you were first getting started and
i'm you know it's like how
you say things that people are usually
afraid to say
you know like i feel like i have a lot
of opinions and i have but i
filter myself a lot because i you know
and maybe for me it's like i'm running
this big business that is
you know i mean listen if i around
election time if i ever say how i feel
or what i think
inevitably like i posted something
recently from um
joel olsen who i think he's a pretty rad
dude i like him
i posted and a lot of people were like i
can't believe you support this guy
i'm unfollowing you which is like
whatever i don't [ __ ] care you can
unfollow me
but i'm like here's the that's the thing
i'm like [ __ ] i have to be so
i i live in this like walk the line
everyone's everywhere
everyone and it's like we live in this
cancel culture where everyone's so
[ __ ] mad about [ __ ] everything and
it's like you
seem to like rise above that and i guess
you know you don't
care it's it's you know it's funny i
don't i'm a human
this is actually actually you know i've
been in my feelings
lately which is gonna i'm really excited
because i'm gonna give you a really good
interview
i can i can feel it already i
talk a lot about not caring um and i
in the macro i do not and what i mean by
that is
i actually care about everything i
actually
genuinely care what i mean by that is
i'm curious i'm appreciative i'm not
delusional
i'm empathetic this is that person's
point of view of me they're more right
than i
am i don't want to be audacious or tone
deaf
what i mean by i don't care is i know
that if somebody
is spewing venom at me
on my page i'm
emotionally aware enough to know oh crap
that person's in a tough spot that like
the thought
i don't have time to consume
content of people i admire and enjoy
the thought of taking time to consume
something of someone i don't
and then have to spend the energy to
think of something to write
to hurt that person yeah life is
very basic how you feel about yourself
is how you are going to come to the
table
on how you're going to treat the other
person it's just true
yeah no i feel like you say the same
adrian says the same thing it's like
every now and again we get some haters
on our pages and it's like and your your
respect your first response is like that
person must be really unhappy
you know it's like that's and i do truth
and i do two things at the same time you
train i definitely do that i'm like what
would make someone to go that deep if
it's not constructed
i get some great stuff hey gary the
audio's too loud or like hey i really
disagree with you on this point because
now i'm like oh this is too loud right
sure
no sure that stuff i love that's no i
mean like you're a piece of [ __ ] or
you know like you know like you're a
terrible dad yeah or
right or like you only care about
yourself or like you know coming at it
or like
hot somebody yesterday you're just full
of unbelievable amounts of hot air and
i'm like cool but like
it's how i feel about you ali again back
to that moment
i'm on probably like my fifth
substantially successful business
from either scratch or the one business
my dad had small to huge right which was
the hardest of them all because it's
family dynamics
right this is not
luck at this point like all the excuses
of what i've done
you know like you're gonna lose when
you're gonna go that route with me
and so that becomes like straight need
to tear someone else down
now at the same token when i go into
compassion
which is what i would say when i see
that i go into compassion mode
i also do a very weird thing i go
literally i can feel myself doing it
right now do not get high on your own
supply what i mean by that is i am
so scared to get subconsciously sold out
that i start what i do extremely well is
when i get tremendous accolades you guys
were very nice to me on the right now
i swear to god i do something very weird
i go into don't listen to it
be so grateful because if you hear the
cheering
you become susceptible to the booing
think a lot about this with beauty gosh
that's so good
sorry keep going yeah let me finish this
and but don't lose your thought if you
grow up and somebody says to you you're
pretty you're pretty that's seventh
grader
that is right you're pretty you're
pretty you're pretty you're pretty
you're pretty
going to be in trouble when you're older
where your now identity is based on your
pretty
yeah you're speaking my language well
listen i think about this a lot or
you're good at school and then school
just gets taken away from you and now
it's real life and you know
business was great for me you're good at
business that became my validation well
uh oh
this is forever so i'm still in my
bubble i'm never getting quote unquote
holder
i'm never leaving school so the thought
of like
academics looks sports
because only one percent of one percent
of one percent gets to the final place
the business affirmation this is my
great luck
look at this look at these goosebumps i
don't know if you guys see them
oh you do andre i got lucky my place of
validation because we all have it i'm
not an
alien yeah my place of validation was oh
you suck at all these things
you're not you're cute but you're not
overly like every girl's dying
he said that sports but you're not going
to the league you're terrible at school
so now my only validation is who i
became
i only had validation as a child for two
things like crazy validation like the
like the big stuff one i was crazy good
at business
as a kid crazy good lemonade stand
garage sales
baseball cards i was doing crazy ass
[ __ ] making 100 bucks at nine
is crazy in 19 [ __ ] 84. right
and number two big validation on this is
so funny i've never said this this way
i was nice i was nice as [ __ ]
yeah i was nice to every kid that got
picked on i was there
everybody like i was inclusive i was
nice
i like stood up for people i was nice
i was nice and so who am i at 45 years
old now
i'm a businessman who pushes nice
yeah yeah no it's so true i mean gosh
it's like there's so much of what you're
saying that resonates with me i mean i
think that i
have fallen into that trap too of like
you're right whenever i get introduced
and i'm speaking at something and you
know if they play this video and they
say all this stuff and i'm like
and i do walk out like on a cloud you
know and then i'm and then you're right
and then i'm so susceptible when someone
doesn't like me or someone you know i
like recently someone like went on a
rant on my instagram about how
i'm so full of [ __ ] i'm so inauthentic
and i'm like
[ __ ] you i'm not inauthentic what are
you talking about i'm not authentic
at all i'm actually like overly
authentic what the [ __ ] and
you know found myself like going letting
myself go down this rabbit hole but
because
i'm so accustomed to like the 10 years
of actually
i've been given it
struggle in life constant affirmation on
this game
then the game gets pulled from
underneath them it's a
very tough and i was a shitty and i was
a shitty student i didn't go to college
i
barely made it through high school you
know and so it was like the [ __ ] bar
yeah because then life was so awesome
for you because it was like
that's why entrepreneurship worked for
you same for me yeah
yeah i i'm in a really big place in my
life where i'm like
i don't i i basically live life like
this i know i mean nothing
in the universe yeah and i and i wake up
every day trying to be the most
important human on earth
i swear to god it is such a crazy
[ __ ] thing
and this is back to me and my feelings
i'm in this point in my life where i'm
like
okay [ __ ] man like shit's gonna get wild
these next 30 years
like i'm gonna like everyone on earth is
gonna know who i am at 75.
this is a huge responsibility comma
why right you go into these and so
and and i think it's what i right now my
running thesis is what i just said to
you
my awareness of my complete
non-importance because if i die tomorrow
i know exactly what will happen
my inner circle will be devastated i'm
such the glue to my family and like my
inner circle
uh the next circle my companies and
things that
crushed right because financial
stability and just enjoyment the next
circle
lightweight friends acquaintances really
disturbed
ally right you andrew like oh that's
like that [ __ ] that that sucks
i'll get the little photo of me and ally
doing a podcast this photo right now
this moment you'll be like
this is a real loss he really just
interviewed him yeah exactly
but 29 hours later
nine 99.99999999999999999999999999 of
the world goes right back to their life
sure
right so that's perspective it's a huge
perspective because it's
because it's what i it's why people that
know me the best
talk about humility whereas people who
just see me on instagram
peacocking around something are like
what
yeah it's the last word i think of that
[ __ ] guy with
yeah but that's i'm sorry let me stick
with it because i just want to finish
this thought
good but on the flip side every day i'm
like [ __ ] my parents had sex at the
right exact moment
my life's circumstances with russia and
america immigrant and
internet did it all these things in the
world even nfts the way i think about it
right now
all happened for me at the right time
the universe conspired and i have a
communication style
that is so unique for some reason
that i can change the world i can make
november 14th an american holiday that i
when i die
in 45 years my birthday
can be which makes no sense because
right now i'm a businessman and to do
that you have to be
a social a political you have to be so
but i'm like
so and i what and so i'm so in that play
do you know how insanely polar opposite
that is that is pulling
from such extreme directions that is my
actual makeup and i know that's probably
why
weird [ __ ] is happening but i'll let you
go back to what you were thinking adrian
well
i prove who i don't know if i'm gonna
remember what i was thinking then
but now it's well no this is great
because i mean it seems like
it seems polar i don't know that it is
in this way is that at least for you
that's the only way it could work
because if you were going to go be an
ego maniac you would actually
hate yourself i would have been long
gone well yeah well you would have
if you're such a family-centered guy go
ahead forget about not only that
if i was who the people that most
disliked me
sure wanted me to be yeah the amount of
access
i give to people i have unlimited film
teams follow me all the time
my there's 75 people that have my email
40 people on my team
that i don't even know for more than
three months have access to my instagram
and my accounts like i yeah like i
figured out that my good behavior
allowed me to create scale
yeah yes the reason a lot of people
don't scale
is they're worried about the skeleton
you're right yes
yeah well and i also think it's
important to like talk about what you
were saying about being nice you know
it's like there's so many [ __ ] out
there
you know people who are at the top of
companies who are just you know
you're right the skeletons it's like you
know they don't want to right they don't
want to
build a personal brand discover all the
way there because they know if they get
too big there's a tipping point yeah and
then everyone's going to try to tear
them down because that's what america
does
that's and i feel like i have lots of
friends who work you know for you know
working companies and they're like you
know their boss is like
founders big famous founders who's like
their boss is such an
[ __ ] you know and i'm like it's just
yeah god it's like
be nice i mean i feel like that all like
i feel like i've tried
you know i mean i definitely have my
moments but i feel like being nice is
like
you know if you can do nothing else you
know that that is that is something that
gets you so far
the reason i've been able to win is
because when bad things happen i'm in my
most
calm this and this is something i want
to talk about because you just put up
something because i
love your spirit alley and i just
listened to you carefully and when you
said i have my moments and
with my intuitive chemicals i go right
she and many other nice people
have those moments because of a high
intense moment
right like something bad happens my dad
did this quite a bit and my dad's on the
other side of this
he would get stress and it would
formulate in a tornado of everyone
around him
yeah and i became very visceral to it i
think i naturally would have been this
but i think my dad's reverse style to me
where i saw the carnage
of sure anxiety manifesting in
bad behavior to communication to the
people around them
yeah i think i became even a more
extreme version of what i probably would
have naturally been
had i not been in my dad's business and
watched sure because i became this young
yeah i was the yang i was like [ __ ] that
i hate this dad
you're not being nice yeah it really
bothered me be diplomatic yeah but
but i realized over time years later as
i got older i'm like oh my dad was
scared
i'm not scared why am i not scared oh
weird i
actually don't care about money oh weird
i actually don't care about nice things
i don't need [ __ ] i don't like
i don't need a car i don't need a rolex
i don't care what [ __ ] anybody thinks
about what house or apartment i have oh
i have the shitty apartment oh i have
the not as good card oh i
don't look like somebody else flies
private i fly commercially
i don't give a [ __ ] you what my life has
not what are you
and so once i started understanding like
oh right
i'm in business people get most anxious
when their money could be affected go
out of business make less money lost
money
i always reacted by being the bigger man
that was the time when i could be the
biggest mentor to my people they just
did something bad we lost money
they think i'm gonna kill them i walk in
and i love them oh my god now we're
family
yeah and that has been my foundation
that's why people stay with me for such
a long time that's why i have so much
continuity
in my company that that don't usually
have continuity liquor stores
agencies these are turn and burns and i
have sevens nines twelves
because of how i treat them yeah gosh
and that's because and that's because
when kovac uh let's go really real
this is very difficult to say because
cobin was so devastating
covet comes and there's that like fourth
day in when you're like oh this is bad
yeah right right yeah yeah i like that
right this is real
like oh this is not just the news
yeah this is not only not the news this
is not going to be two weeks
yeah yeah remember that i when i heard
the first day two weeks i'm like [ __ ]
when i was four when i was four days in
i'm like oh this could be a while
and then about a month then you're like
oh this could be the
and it's more than that now now we're
into april the next year anyway
nonetheless
i remember having this huge sense of
calm as my cfo started telling me the
carnage
of all the phone calls from our clients
saying they're going to need an extra
100 days
200 days 150 days to pay how
overextended we are
where we are in this where we're on that
leases and then
the kicker we're getting nothing because
we fall in the middle
and so we're getting no government
support
when i tell you that sword through my
chest
landed in the following way literally i
remember it like
four seconds goes in my parents house
huh i've been talking a lot about being
a wartime general and being the captain
during rough seas
this is gonna be it this is it and i
[ __ ] drilled it i will for many you
know
i don't think the time of like how well
you navigated the business during covid
i don't think it's the
right time to talk about that with how
much pain there still is but in 12 years
in nine years i'll absolutely talk about
details
because i'll feel you know we'll be more
removed it'll just be the way wounds
work
and there'll be a lot of lessons to
share because and i've been
prepared for it my whole life because
i'm a wartime general
i i tell my managers and my leaders
and this is the number one thing i think
about are like uh gary
why are you so upset with me this is
only the first time i've acted like this
to my team i'm like
john it's the first time there was any
pressure
you've been here for six months it's
been [ __ ] smooth sailing the second
there was a fire
you [ __ ] it flamed instead of took
out you're the leader
too many people are peacetime generals
everyone's a hero bj
armstrong's really good at basketball
when he has michael jordan with him
what about what about when it's hard
yeah yeah yeah that makes sense
well i mean did you not sorry good i
mean but you know when that was that
when that result when the [ __ ] was all
you know you have you have many
businesses when
when that was all happening and you know
how did you like
how did you like you know what do you do
to keep yourself from like being you
know i mean i understand the whole not
caring about
money in the traditional that was a big
one i
i'm being serious this is why it's
really important you play out
okay first please god everybody be
healthy i'm scared
yeah you know i i navigate the next six
months
and triple our business but my mom dies
of coven am i happy
get the [ __ ] out of here i'm dead so if
you go first to what you actually care
about perspective
second to your point i was like look it
could go like if it goes to zero i'll
start again like i'm not kidding
like like i don't you know i don't know
that's so funny because that's what
that's exactly what i used to tell
people when we were starting dry bar and
i would get interviewed and people were
like
are you you know were you scared this
wasn't work i was like well no one's
gonna die it was i mean i've been i've
been quoted a million times saying this
nobody's gonna die we're all gonna lose
some money and then we're pretty smart
people
will find other [ __ ] to do that was you
know i was like no so there wasn't a lot
of fear for me and losing the money i
guess you know i guess it's similar
to how you know to what you're saying it
was like just nobody's gonna die you
know it's like they're
the worst case scenario is not death
here the worst case scenario is like we
start all over again
so i can totally relate to that mike my
question would be gary is you
because you seem like you know that
moment is made for you you made yourself
for that moment that's probably both
true you know you've decided to be a
wartime general maybe
you're you're you know you know part of
its nature but it's a lot nurture and
hyper commitment um for you
as the founder and the ceo and you know
the
the leader that everybody looks to and
they tell me about how you scale that
behavior but even deeper scale that
belief system
uh inside the hearts and minds of your
up and c of your leadership
especially when those that are they are
in that moment losing their [ __ ] and
their worst colors are showing
how do you intervene and then program in
co coaching coaching and firing
yep tell us more
if you're going to scale it yeah you
have to be willing to cut
loose with people who are too far along
into their dna
that no matter how much you go in you're
not
able to give enough therapy coaching
long leash support and then you become
um i'm in a very tough spot because i
speak about these things quite a bit i
have people in my company who i'm still
trying to coach up
but they also are creating the
vulnerability of me being a hypocrite
i know every i know right now that
somebody's in a meeting with somebody
i'm still coaching that's a major leader
yeah that that leader's doing something
completely against my principles
and the people in that room are saying
gary's full of [ __ ] cause this person's
getting away with why is he letting
gosh yes tell me though how long do you
let how long do you let it roll
i let it roll differently based on every
best yeah that this is what's tough
about inter
you know because i do an interview like
this desperately yeah
i'm desperately here for one reason how
can one person listening to this epic
podcast
that either a knows me or doesn't know
me but hears something in a certain way
that triggers because this is how we all
live someone says something
it changes your perspective you go taste
it you're like i love oysters
i never thought i liked oysters they're
the best and so that's what i'm trying
to do right now and
and i hate this question not hate i
struggle with it because
it's it's custom it's everywhere every
single person
you see do you see trap you know what
happens right ali i saw your reaction
you're coaching someone's moving along
and you're like oh [ __ ] we made the turn
and then they do the [ __ ] same thing
and you're like yeah see i just don't
i'm such a like high or slow fire fast
you know and it had happened to me so
many times
over the course of dry bar where i'm
like nope you guys no this person
doesn't get it they're never going to
get it it's never going to happen and
they want to like
spend all this time and i'm like it's
never going to [ __ ] happen they don't
get it and i'm higher fast
when you're in hyper growth higher fast
fire faster and promote fastest
yeah there's a very big mistake that
people make when
by the way for everybody al and i have
had the luxury of being in hyper growth
companies
so this is not for everybody because
listen if you're hiring like we hire 30
people a week right now
there is no other version besides fire
high or fast
like if you hire you know yeah no i feel
like i feel like that's true i just like
literally hired a girl last
this past week who i had like a phone
interview with and i really liked her
and i hired her and i was like wait i
don't hire a slob
i hired her like up no you know about
recommendation
you hire
but i also just don't have time for it
if it's not [ __ ] working i cannot
stand it like it's also it's also can't
it's also cancer
yes yes it's you're you're also creating
vulnerabilities i've had a tough
firings in the last year and they [ __ ]
on you and
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] this and you were the
worst
and you know it goes from you their best
friend a week ago you're the worst and
they start making [ __ ] up and
it's devastating as a human i [ __ ]
hate it mike
you ready you ready to really be blown
away let me go vulnerable
my greatest weakness over the last 25
years as an operator and ceo and leader
of companies which i've been every day
of my life since i've been a
professional
is candor how about that bomb because
gary vee
like the person that puts out contents
of the world best camera guy going
shoot that's right no [ __ ] right
right you said it earlier ali
but in my companies i hate negativity so
much and i
fall in love with my and i feel like i'm
their dad and leader or brother
i've really struggled with it and it
took me
a long time to get to where i am now
which oh by the way
i still think it's my disproportionate
weakest trait
amongst all these 12 to 25 things that i
think really matter
and that's cool right like that's cool
to be self-aware and have the humility
and
what is your weakest trait the the
sweet people through the years yeah and
being very disappointed in their work
they come in for a check-in
and not saying one thing about it yeah
you'll avoid it
completely avoiding it because i didn't
like the confrontation yeah
and what i would do is i would try to
coach up on
offense use practical optimism
instead of candor once in a while that
would work
but i've become different and i'm
working on it and it's helped me a lot
yeah it's also why i believe in
accountability humility
yeah table and all the other things i do
well because it shows
because i know these ingredients really
matter yeah for you what's the math on
that so the math is
it's oh to just talk about that because
that's like uh
and yeah i mean there's 55 ideas i know
you don't want to be pops right you
don't want to be the frank
under stress that that was huge
i can't even realize that to be very
very naked here
my father is great at candor strength
frank the problem is he delivered it
with such venom yes that i was
unable maybe because i started seeing it
at 14 so i was so young in my
development
and now i'm going deep that my intuition
and more than intuition for this
audience is that
i was unable to unpack the vessel that
was delivering the candor from the value
of candor
right and i demonized the whole thing
yes and i
and i'm only unpacking that now and it's
crazy because i'm so good at it publicly
yeah and i'll tell you why ali on stage
i'm talking to the world
right when you're prescribing you can't
i mean it's personal gear right
here it's this is sound intimate and
i'll tell you where i get destroyed
this is sally her husband has cancer
yeah he's the provider i get i get
destroyed on this one
he's 187 000 in debt in college i know
it
and then there was early in my career it
was ego
this guy who makes eight bucks an hour
as a stock boy will never get a better
job for somebody who likes him more
takes care of him more than me
so when i fire him and he goes to shop
right it's gonna be worse and i don't
want that for him
i gotta figure it out it was ego now
it's it's compassion heart
right it's i know too much i'm so deep
in my [ __ ]
and my culture i know too much i know
what's going on in their family life
i know stuff yeah and it's and that's
very
valuable so what do you do with that
that that employee now
hold on a second so let me can i dance
here for a second because
this is what i'm curious about because
it seems like i hear that
that okay i don't because an empathetic
reason and i get it and i buy it by the
way i buy that but that's true for you
it just seems like historically has been
like this either or either
i'm you know if i'm honest i'm a dick or
i'm a
you know or i'm like i'm loving by the
way
you've got this right it's a game of and
not or
in this one subject matter amen yeah in
this vulnerability that i had in my 25
years of leadership
yeah i did it i didn't have it as the
aunt everywhere else i do
that's why i'm winning sure everywhere
else in paradox
everywhere else i'm gray it's both black
and white right
here i was black and white couldn't
unravel it just started unraveling over
the last five years slowly
but that's even a little bit of [ __ ]
because five years ago i probably moved
it from
zero to five percent but at least i
started in the last
year and a half it's really moved call
my strengths
90s and like the things i do well
accountability the
innovation leaders call this one
literally
a 10 five years ago that moved to 20
but in the last 18 months has moved from
30 to
67. good for you so uh so and and
and by the way it's probably why i'm
ready to talk about it right yeah
because you know like
you know when i was in it you know it's
funny it's not like i was
interested in hiding it i actually am
happy that i can talk about this now
because i want to talk more about
vulnerabilities it's that i didn't
see it yeah yeah it was the water you're
swimming in
you know but it also it also it also
really relies on humility early in my
career was ego
and later in my career it was ego and
ego is something you know
people confuse confidence with ego a lot
sure ego ego is insecurity
confidence is not ego is just insecurity
with makeup on to peacock
right and so uh i was
sad scared for them and for the
ramifications of how i would put my head
on my
i live for my head on my pillow sure it
took me time to understand
the real answer which is even if
something atrocious is going on in
someone's home
once i've made the binary decision that
they are traumatically
incapable of doing their job here
they've been undermined
so sure they're not nothing good is
happening so i'm giving up for the wrong
reason correct
so now now i try to be very graceful you
know you can do nice packages you can do
nice things
and then people have to do their thing
and so you know i'm working on it
mike's my experience is being like i
call them like the nice guys and
and you know i coach execs for a living
and so like lots a handful of guys i
work with are like nice guys where it's
like they they're long on like the
empathetic
helpful you know really play the heart
game which is awesome
there's always somewhere in their
universe where they're
they're holding back and they're doing
it for good reason right
and the challenge with well what's
available for nice guys is
two things one is they've there's so
much trust you don't have to say much
they really love you
they really trust you all you've got to
do is say hey tom
i'm really having a hard time because
the results are disappointing to me i
don't know what to do about that and
that works that'll flip tom
in a second and also it's like usually
my experience is nice guys become
can flip because they don't get to the
conversation soon enough
so it's it's about should i fire them or
not it wasn't about should i coach them
in this moment
you got it i couldn't agree with and i
couldn't agree with what you just said
more
comma my great job
as the ceo of my companies is to
eliminate fear and i do it
in so many goddamn ways i put myself
out front as a persona which means i get
all the heat and i mean
sure i internally take on
incredible amounts of accountability i'm
also the disproportionate
force of growth i'm a nice person i do a
lot of things
no kidding when i got to that place two
years ago where i was like
[ __ ] me this candor thing
means that a lot of people don't know
where they stand because they get
stunned by the hire
and that is creating massive fear ugh i
wanted to jump out the [ __ ] window on
hot stakes with [ __ ] duty on them
you know like um and so it's been a
great
it's been great you know like it's been
great it happen it will still rear its
head
i've created a much bigger we call it
kind candor at vayner now
kind of because i think people use
candor as an excuse to not be nice
sure right yeah it's like oh i'm gonna
give it to you straight and then you're
like [ __ ]
you're like you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah
hey john i'm gonna give this straight
you [ __ ] suck
you know it's like you know no no no no
there's a different way to do this so
anyway nonetheless i'm glad we got into
that part
i want to touch on anything else you
wanted to get to in these last 10
minutes well it's cool i mean just
this is this is the way we talk about it
it's this paradox between diplomatic and
frank
right so what you want to be is both
it's a both hand world yeah tell the
truth and in a way that works for other
people
you know but that's a commitment
question you live that commitment you
care about people i think about all the
time i think about because i've got a
seven-year-old and a five-year-old
like celebrating the [ __ ] out of when
they do something that's beautiful
because of the stories you've told about
when you'd hold the door open and your
mom would go nuts
i really i really think about that thank
you thank you for saying that thank you
for even knowing that story thank you
for picking up on that
and it is my number one yeah reinforce
going four for four at a baseball game
is fun to cheer
being drop dead cute in your outfit when
you're 11 years old
is a thing is nice but make sure that
the majority of the cheering
is around things that look like you were
nice to that person that skinned their
knee
my son the child is such good
when my son shows a lot of empathetic
you know things
when he like like goes and hugs a kid
who had a bad app
this happened hug the kid who had a bad
day at baseball
i mean i'm i basically am treating him
like he won the nobel peace prize
well you know i mean something like that
just happened with me this past weekend
my
my now you know almost 14 year old son
was with my
my in-laws my brother's in-laws and they
i saw them later in the day and they
said you know
i have to tell you that you know we
spoke to kit he looked us in the eyes
and i remember
he didn't he never used to look us in
the eyes when he talked to him and he
they
they praised him for it they're like man
kit you're so engaged
it's so nice to talk to you you really
look us in the eyes and you didn't used
to do that and he said it was my mom
my mom would say you gotta look people
in the eyes you gotta like connect with
people you can't
it's rude it's disrespectful to talk to
somebody and not look them in the eyes
and he credited me for saying that to my
in-laws and i almost
i mean she makes me tear up thinking
about it because i almost fell on the
ground i was like
i remember talking to him about that a
lot when he was little
and the fact that like it stuck and that
was something that i praised him for
is those things and my kids are the kids
who hugged the kid that fell down and my
kids are the kids who want to
help the bullies you know and i imagine
it's it's selling it's because of
celebrating
those things but while we're here we're
doing a little parent life
let me get into something that is a real
concern of mine
and back to where garyvee does a good
job and where gary vaynerchuk is doing a
much better job with vaynerx the last
three years
versus six years ago if we do not
celebrate accountability
our kids will be disasters yes
so praise the bully thing but when they
are in this
excuse life or when they're complaining
about
the machine and the answer isn't
what are you gonna do about it yeah
we have allowed an entire culture of
people
to be in the excuse and dwelling and
everything is some macro government
parents society business this
it is everything else but themselves now
here's an important thing to
hear it might be true
well stick with me here i want to finish
this thought yeah
there might be incredible validity to
one's point
because it's a both game you could be
right that you were born on the wrong
side of tracks
you could be right that america's doing
this you could be right that coca-cola
is doing that
yes a big thing that happens next is now
what
so for example i analyze [ __ ] so what
know what
right so it's yes and now what
so in the hospital yeah so we're on the
same track like to me
i'm like you're right now what because
the thing that scares me
is we have gotten to a place because of
the way humans communicate in society
where for example parents blame
social media for their kids being
insecure not the fact that they're not
parenting their kid
right right we've gotten to a place
where somebody feels that if they send
out a tweet
they've done something about something
yes or that if they tear somebody else
down
and they noble shame them but they don't
realize hypocrisy because they're doing
something else
that is like we are in a delusional
state of non-accountability
yes yeah well we see this i mean we're
blending families now so i've got the
five and seven
she's got the 13 and 16 and
um you know even even when my kids when
they go to their mom's house and they
forgot he forgot his switch well i'm
like sorry dude
i'm not bringing it over that's it you
know and he's seven
it's like and by the way and by the way
by the way
that's a tough one i have a lot of
compassion for you
because you're you're you're saying that
it for parents that are listening that
have easier situations of accountability
and don't do it now i'm putting myself
in your shoes
you're in a place where you're going
through you know your his parents are
he's a little guy
his parents are divorced that's a lot of
heaviness to begin with we demonize that
one we shouldn't have but that's our
culture
and like you know most parents are
massively over compensating on
accountability
sure not accountable that's where i fall
yeah we talk about it a lot this is a
big conversation in this house i want to
save my children all the time and do
everything for them and i if adrian has
really helped me
see that and be like oh [ __ ] let them do
it you know
yes yes i told ali if you give the boys
if you give the boys enough space
they'll become men it's so real guys
please please world please hear us right
now god
tap into this phone line right now
please we
are making a mistake around
accountability eighth place trophies
have destroyed
yes i was just thinking trophies you
read my mind i was like where did it
change that like every kid gets a
[ __ ] trophy
if they didn't win like i'm like that is
not i'm like i don't want to play in
that league
sports sports helped sports helped us so
much
i cried from 8 to 16 i cried once a week
because i lost in something
it is the foundation of my happiness i
swear
you know it's like i just said in an
interview for the first time and i don't
think i ever said this publicly but like
i
in high school tried out for
cheerleading every year and i wanted it
so [ __ ] bad i just had this idea i
wanted to be a cheerleader i loved the
outfit i loved the
the you know the status it was the
status and i never [ __ ] made it not i
tried out
every year and i never made it and it
like and i never like talked about it
but it crushed me
and it made me feel like shitty like i
wasn't good enough for years but
probably really
helped me it's awesome because it's real
life
in real life when you're 31 your mommy's
not coming over and buying you a pony
because he didn't make the cheerleading
team
like like i don't understand what people
see guys
we have an entire generation of mid-20s
to early 30 year olds
whose parents are paying for their lives
still yeah yep
yep it's bad it's bad
because then they're then those parents
are in control
then when the kids and parents are
having discussions and the kids 27 and
they want to do something
the parent has the money hanging over
nobody says it
in the argument but everybody knows the
score which is if you don't listen to
your mommy and daddy
they're going to pull the cash and then
you can't have the bmw and the equinox
membership it's all this [ __ ] yeah
it's all this bull [ __ ] [ __ ] stand up
and be happy what's the loss of the
individual i mean
i i had a i had a huge uh vc firm out
here
call me and say hey will you do
diversity and inclusion training which i
don't i never
do stuff like that it's it's i don't
actually agree with most of what's
happening these days and i said why
don't we have
a leadership conversation about
everybody takes themselves
responsible about how we treat one
another now there's a lot to be learned
about
xyz but it's a leadership it's a
leadership conversation
i i'm i'm obsessed with dni only because
it's a proxy to the thing that you later
laddered it up to
amen this is about this is about
stability that's right
this is about like like where are we on
our humanity towards
and by the way there's another thing
this goes back to insecurity why
can i ask you this everyone who's
listening and obviously the three of us
why do you need to convince people to
see the world exactly like you what is
this going right
what is this obsession i have
ready for this on the record i have
conviction
about every belief i have it's in my
soul i believe i'm emotionally
intelligent
i believe that i've lived a really
extreme kind of like diverse life
i have deaf deep conviction some of them
are by political standards on this side
some are on that side
some are nuanced some of my religious
standards on this side and that side
by culture side this side that side i
have
zero interest in anybody
doing what i do or believing what i
believe in i
have like why i ignore enormous interest
in believing my thing not trying to do
bad by anybody
and having respect for other people's
thing and when we have a conversation
where we don't agree
enjoy the discourse for thoughtfulness
and evolution but everyone's so insecure
and wants everyone to believe what they
believe it's the safety of the crowd
it's the loss of the individualism i
think it connects the parenting
conversation connects to the cultural
conversation
you know people being convicted about
something for themselves versus hiding
in the crowd that's what i'm
usually after conviction and convincing
but but listen
50 are going to agree with you anyway
that's plenty that's 150 million america
good news everyone 150 million americans
agree
yeah it's such a good point it's like i
want people to agree with me all the
time but why
like it doesn't really [ __ ] matter
you know i want people to see things
when i see things but why
right what you want to do where people
where i think we've
gotten into a bad places we've gotten
into a place where
the world politically for sure which is
really what we're referencing
has gotten into straight childish
behavior yes
we are in complete this is back to
civility we're it's not
we don't even know we're just in like
literally like we're in such
bad behavior we've demonized
we've made it us against them yes and
that is devastating
listen fear is an incredibly big power
and they're from the beginning it's fear
is an incredibly big
star wars nailed this the dark side
and the jedis are awfully close that's
why even the bad guys sometimes win and
the good guy dies they're damn close
but [ __ ] there's nothing i believe in
more
than that the good and the love wins in
the end yeah
buy a neck buy a deck sometimes in times
or buy a mile it all just depends on
what era you're born in the world
and i'll leave i'll leave with this and
i obviously have gone over but i'm just
having too much fun with you too
because i'm trying to drop seeds that
you guys may build on and you'll bring
other people on and bounce to this this
one is
interesting to me the notion of you find
what you're looking for
we now are in a place where people are
spending all their time looking for bad
yeah i can go on the internet or on
mainstream media or outside right now
and in an hour find an ungodly amount of
bad
in an hour i can also
easily oh by the way on the record
easier find a stunning amount of good
people choose yeah
it's good i need i needed this i needed
to hear all this this was really good
and i think a lot of people will feel
that way because i think i tend to go
towards that too where i can easily find
the bad
or even like even on my own you know
personal platform like i
you know i'm sure you heard speaking of
the bad you know there was this shooting
yesterday of this young kid
and you know and this whole thing and
i'm like oh and then i was like i don't
want to [ __ ] post anything today
because i don't want to be like
disrespectful to the fact that this bad
thing happened and i don't want to be
like
you know talking about the good things
that are happening in my life but i'm
like that doesn't make sense
ali ali there are millions of people
in the world millions that
have to go hours to get somewhat clean
water
do not have clean water in the world
right now
there is genocide in the world like
we are animals you know how you like
step on a bug by accident
like you know or like we are animals
there are things that are going to
happen there's like there's survival
good bad insulin like it's heavy
but like how we choose to treat each
other
as a reflection of what's going on in
ourselves
is the most interesting conversation
yeah
yes if we can be generous to ourselves
forgiving of ourselves get back up go
again
i mean living in the living in the now
what yeah um so man thank you so much
for your time gary
yep love your legacy man thank you
brother bye youtube watcher what's up
it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon